congress and president biden president
biden is pushing congress and the states
by the way to suspend the federal gas
tax for three months kind of summer
holiday to provide americans with a
little relief from these high prices at
the pump the nationwide average for a
gallon of regular is a little less than
five dollars right now and in 14 states
the average is more than five dollars in
the state of virginia the average price
of regular is 4.78 cents a gallon which
is a more than 60 percent increase from
just a year ago and i bring that up
because virginia governor glenn younkin
has requested a gas tax holiday in the
state's new budget and he got it
rejected
the legislature uh rejected it and the
governor is here with us so we're going
to talk about the gas tax off the top
thank you for being here for good
morning thank you for having me back you
said i could come back and i appreciate
you having me
yeah we do absolutely uh i always like
the highlighters i always like to
highlight a little bit of bipartisanship
and it sounds like president biden who
wants this uh gas tax holiday and
yourself are in the same camp at the
moment you both support it yeah i felt
like the easiest way as a governor to
give virginians a break when we can
afford it in virginia is to suspend our
gas tax for three months it's roughly 26
cents a gallon and unfortunately our
senate led by democrats said no and i've
sent the bill down three times and
they've said no three times and i don't
understand why because this is such an
easy way for us to give virginians a
break we have plenty of money in our
commonwealth transportation fund over a
billion dollars more than we anticipated
this cost a little over 400 million
dollars to provide this break and i
think virginia's deserve it and i think
we should get this done yeah with the
president calling for it with you
calling for it i think for your state
and many others it might be coming but
we'll have to wait and see uh something
else that might be coming is this big
decision from the supreme court could
overturn roe v wade in virginia abortion
access is legal up to 25 weeks you've
talked about dialing it down to 20 weeks
if roe v wade is overturned what's going
to happen in your state well first what
we've been focused on is keeping our
justices safe and
this leak was done to cause chaos and
parading and picketing in front of the
justices homes in order to influence
them is wrong and so
we saw this assassination temp on
justice kavanaugh in maryland and it's
just kept us all very very on a
heightened awareness to make sure our
justices are safe and and this final
ruling will come down and if and if it's
delivered as expected my first job is to
keep virginians safe and so we're going
to protect our constitutional right to
protest if people want to protest and
demonstrate but we're also going to
enforce the law and make sure there's no
violence and so we've coordinated with
mayors and local police and state police
to make sure that people get to express
their constitutional rights but we're
going to keep people safe and if they
break the law we're going to but what
about women who may be worried about
their abortion rights i hear we all
agree we want everybody to be safe we
get that but no one wants to see
protesters outside supreme court
justices right home or them endangered
but what do you say to women in virginia
who may be worried
well first of all nothing changes
immediately in virginia uh and what
we're going to do is work with our
legislature i'm a pro-life governor and
i've got to work with our legislature to
to see the next path and so we'll start
those discussions um it's going to
require a cooperation between our
legislators and the governor in order to
get something done and we're going to
start that work so it sounds like you
don't really want to say until we know
exactly what the decision is going to be
yeah we don't know yet i mean i think
there's a lot of
supposition on what it's going to say
based on the based on the the leaked
draft opinion but we need to wait to see
what it says and then we'll work with
our legislature and go to and go to work
as a team from there so if you're
pro-life
can can we ask about that because i'm
worried about the clock ticking the the
january 6 committee hearings that are
going on right now where we've seen time
after time trump advisers telling the
president at the time listen you lost he
is still refusing to acknowledge that
even as we sit here today do you think
that's hurting your party and do you
believe first do you believe that joe
biden was elected president of this
country i i do believe that joe biden
was elected president of this country
and i think what happened on january 6
was awful awful um it's a it was a real
blight on our democracy
i have to be honest though i talk to
virginians every day and what they're
talking about is not january 6. what
they're talking about is runaway
inflation they're talking about gas
prices through the roof grocery prices
they're worried about crime in their
local neighborhoods we're all talking
about that governor but this is also
very important because there are so many
conflicting things where people say oh
it's just tourists that got out of
control it was not a big deal i mean i
do think it's important that the record
reflect accurately what happened do you
think it's hurting your republican party
well let me let me start again i think
the media cares a lot more about this
than the people that the people do and
we can tell i mean there's there's prime
time coverage and candidly not many
people are watching it and this is
because around the kitchen tables in
virginia and i think america it's
runaway inflation it's crime it's
schools these are the issues that
virginians and i think americans are
worried about and this is why this bill
we signed yesterday which is our budget
delivery delivers lower taxes
big investment into schools big
investment into law enforcement this is
why i think virginians are excited about
what we're doing is because we're
focused on these kitchen table issues
that are most important and i think
that's what governor should be doing
right now you say that you believe that
president biden was elected president um
why wasn't that said loudly at the time
and why individuals like you perpetuated
the lie that the election was stolen
well i don't think i perpetuated the law
i'm not sure
so i was very so i just want to be clear
we ran an election in 2021
um that was clear i won um and i won
clearly and i think we can run elections
that are fair and accurate in virginia
and that's what we're focused on
again i believe that there is a big
focus by the media on this that is
really disconnected with what the
average virginian and the average
american is most focused on yeah these
kitchen table issues are real and when
you see people who make fifty and sixty
thousand dollars a year who see a four
and five thousand dollar a year increase
in their lives from groceries and gases
and utility levels this is what people
are most focused on right now you
mentioned keeping virginia safety i know
we have to go but
the gun law proposal
do you support it when it comes to
funding red flags and background checks
for individuals under 21. yeah so to be
clear i haven't i haven't studied the
law in detail let me tell you what we
did in virginia after these two horrific
shootings uh in in new york and in texas
is we pulled together local educators
and local law enforcement to make sure
we could preempt any god forbid copycat
crime we immediately went to work to
fund extra money in for school resource
officers and we got it in our budget we
in fact signed a bill that would require
schools and law enforcement to
collaborate on school safety plans these
are things that i could do right out of
the box and then finally we're in a
mental health crisis in america we know
it we're in it in virginia and so we
just signed a budget that includes
enhanced funding for mental health
support these are things that we went to
work on immediately and i think that's
as a governor what i can do is take
action immediately to deliver results
for virginians we appreciate you thank
you for joining us thank you for coming
back a third time i'll come back again
all right maybe if you have a governor
about 2024 just multiple yeah well i did
want to ask you about that we'll talk
during the commercial break